let's talk about your lovely daughter it
Christmastime coming up is she all
excited about Santa Claus yeah she's
into it yes very excited that's cool
honey like kids would be you know very
ecstatic you get free stuff that we
can't say they've earned but we do it
why do we do it we just keep doing it we
get to the 25th and we go you know you
are alright but here's some stuff here's
some stuff we don't even get credit for
it well wait we give credit we I don't
know she's gonna I don't want her to
hear this we we go work to make that
money - and go then we go to the stores
at the worst time of year to go to the
store buy it
wrap it stay up late put it together and
then we don't even take the credit we
give we're like hey this this creepy
dude dude in a red very very weird
outfit he he got you this stuff not us
we were asleep we don't care that's not
right no so you heard a lot of
resentment about sin I would like to
tell her she my daughter is 4 I would
love to tell her the truth
I don't want to make her that kid at
school who goes thing hey real and then
the other kids are crying and now my
kids are [ __ ] yeah and then the
parents are like hey thanks for ruining
Christmas when really you want to be
like you're welcome
now you get credit for those presents
you have any friends do you have any
although I'm just a nervous wreck right
now because your daughter's in the green
room yeah yeah hearing this I don't know
I don't know
I didn't leave I didn't leave her with
anyone I didn't have any supervision or
anything is back there drinking beer
doing some of those Christmas lines what
kind of dad are you a you would come to
know what I think I'm pretty cool what I
just said
my daughter drink of beer like this is a
cool dad yeah when she's 20 and it's
like hmm you know if you here's the
thing whether she believes in him or not
that I I I don't know when to tell her
the truth but I I would say I'm getting
very close to it she's four now why is
for no man why why not here's what's so
weird when you finally tell your kid hey
by the way that we made all that up why
would any human being then go okay I'll
look past that for the rest of our lives
oh you're a guy you know what are your
kids a teenager yeah people go i when
they're teenagers watch out you want to
know why they're like that because
probably four years ago you told them
the one thing they thought was a
certainty was an absolute lie and then
they come teenagers you know they're
like you know you could say the f-word
but the point is it's I don't I don't
think that's right i don't think that's
reason why teenagers have trouble when
they're 16 years old is because of the
santa clause men yeah it's Santa Claus
it's the Easter Bunny it's the tooth
fairy
why who decided any of this it was like
let's all live a lie for no reason I
think you have no point at all yeah
I disagree I think you're coming around
yeah you're right I want to go on I want
to see you on this tour I really do why
don't you come and do our shows in
Phoenix right everyone I'll do it you
could literally recommend anything in a
crowd will go yeah he should encode and
have his lower jaw completely removed
[Applause]
four tickets to Aurora's upcoming
stand-up tour go to not tool Bend
dot-com and his podcast pen pals with
Daniel and Rory is available wherever
you get your podcasts and man who's
funnier than Rory Scovel you're
hilarious where is gobble